hey what's going on it's bill burns time
for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday August 14 2017 what's going on
how are ya how's it going oh my god
Paul virzi [ __ ] destroyed last night
on his stand-up special in Tarrytown New
York and I want to thank everybody that
came out for the for the two shows that
we had there and we just I don't know it
just went as good as it could have gone
I felt and I was really proud of them
you know that first one's always you
know you got to figure out how to go up
there and try and be relaxed as you like
holy [ __ ] I'm shooting a special look at
those TV cameras look at the jib camera
swinging by my damn face you know you
got to block all of that know that the
crowds going to be looking at that [ __ ]
do you learn that they have to turn off
the [ __ ] air conditioning because
most of those old venues the AC so
friggin loud it messes with the audio so
you're then going to go out there under
hot lights with HD makeup on with no AC
and progressively through your set it's
going to get hotter so he learned all of
that and you know something god damn it
he saw the fire and he [ __ ] walked
through it and he just I don't know
maybe was it just couldn't have gone any
better
and there you go so we're going to edit
that thing down and hopefully sell it to
one of the goddamn networks that's the
guy that's the goal so congratulations
to Paul virzi that's it he put him to
bed I told that before he went out that
was just like dude just look at it this
way okay you're putting all these jokes
to bed this is it okay go out there and
give them the send-off they deserve
because the second your special comes
out everybody seen that material then
you can't do it again and everybody LBI
coke you already did that
you did that on your last [ __ ]
special no your last special call
chuckles like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with my goddamn computer
I've been having oh my god I have been
having like be worth technology
experiences what is going on why is the
screen just all black then I could not
going to touch it and it does that what
does that mean can I hit escape okay his
game why don't they have an escape
button from your life oh it worked it
worked the old the old escape button you
know this somebody could turn that into
literally like in a move like turning
into a movie a big-time Hollywood movie
you know be the escape button movie you
go in there you can pitch it a you know
that escape button on your keyboard and
your and your laptop they'd be like yeah
yeah ah just a man's guy [ __ ] B he
pushes it you know and he disappears and
all of a sudden his wife is like wait a
minute I thought I'd told you go to
store where where'd he go and then when
every button comes to he's always uh
let's flush the splits flush out this
[ __ ] awful movie he was always in
someplace better at first but then
there's you know he goes to a baseball
game he's like this is amazing and then
you know no one believes that it's true
except for his dumb fat best friend you
know they hit escape again then they're
at a steak house you know they just keep
hitting escape then eventually they
they're some [ __ ] I don't know where
the hell did they go they had escaped
and they end up in [ __ ] Syria a North
Korea that's where you get a note from
the industry cannot be North Korea could
it be going to be like Canada like
Winnipeg what if they went to Winnipeg
that's funny right I just feel like with
today's political climate to say North
Korea I just think that you know then
they're starving and we like the fat
friend that is funny that is
non-threatening I don't know you guys
can finish the rest of the [ __ ] movie
uh anyways so I was very proud of Paul
and all that type of stuff and going to
try to keep the podcast like that
despite the despite all that [ __ ] do
horrible [ __ ] that happened down in
Charlottesville it's just [ __ ] flat I
don't know
I thought I did hear one [ __ ] funny
thing about it I meant you I'm gonna say
who I mentioned it to I mentioned it to
somebody else ago Jesus Christ dude can
you [ __ ] believe that [ __ ] dumb and
shallow so then I goes he goes not what
happened I mean I don't know I don't
that is like I don't I don't know how
you missed it but I mean there literally
is that much information coming out at
you that you could miss all that [ __ ]
that went down there and I mean I don't
even need to comment on what the [ __ ]
went on down there if you're any sort of
a human being and you know that dude in
that [ __ ] car I swear to God like I'm
trying to think of a proper punishment
for that guy and I can't think nothing
is like enough to [ __ ] drag just do
that you know the you know it's funny
about that guy as I bet that guy he's
talked about Isis and how cowardly
terrorism is and then he gets in a car
and does what the [ __ ] he did is just
like it's like I don't know they must
have been obviously beyond joining that
[ __ ] group there's something wrong
with that guy mentally anyways
see that's why I do want to bring it up
where do you go from there and then
[ __ ] Trump I'm done with that guy
guys just no longer funny or anything
he's uh I'm just done with that [ __ ]
guy the fact that he wouldn't just
straight-up denounce it the fact that
he's going to go oh you know this hatred
on both sides hatred on both sides he's
doing like that you know what came first
the chicken or the egg got slavery
slavery came first you [ __ ] dope it's
it's documented it's just so fun like
he's been catering to that racist
fanbase because he needed their votes
I'm not saying everybody voted for Trump
is racist but like for that [ __ ] guy
to do that it's absolutely [ __ ]
reprehensible sickening [ __ ]
sickening okay
and I'm not a [ __ ] you know I'm not
one of these guys that thought the sky
was falling because this guy got into
the office you know everybody freaking
the [ __ ] out like what the [ __ ] was
going to happen but I will just say his
track record on the Klan you know to be
just not even commenting on it and being
you know if I was doing stand-up and
people in the Klan started showing up
you I would be looking what the [ __ ] am
I saying that's making these people be
like oh yeah this guy approves of what
we do it's a very least I'd be like
ain't not for nothing you guys over
there with the hoods on I [ __ ] you
know I'm not down with you guys like
[ __ ] cancer you're morons
you're [ __ ] morons and he never does
it never does it you know and I think he
was just trying to make a joke with the
cops about the hook don't push it just a
lot of [ __ ] that you've seen that that
all that police brutality that's been
going out to make that [ __ ] joke the
guy it's unbelievable and now I'm
hearing like this is what I'm not even
the name [ __ ] names but like all
these you know it's like [ __ ] Taylor
Swift now is going to run for Senate
people we can't go down this [ __ ]
road the very least can we at least
stick with career [ __ ] politicians
can we at least do that can we you know
which would you want like we want me to
be your [ __ ] accountants you want a
comedian to be an accountant
why would you want an actor or a
musician or [ __ ] god knows what else
I just I don't know I don't know what
the [ __ ] were doing now I just I don't
even know what the [ __ ] were doing so
anyways that happened and you know
fortunately it wasn't a big rally you
know did not seem to still a little
little mom-and-pop [ __ ] group which
you know that's about the only good
thing that I took away from it but uh I
don't know you know what's [ __ ] up
about the whole thing though as I said I
wasn't going to talk about it
is when people started texting like did
you watching this [ __ ] so I go online
you know to watch a video of the rally
and all the [ __ ] to see what's going
on and I go on and when I click on it I
immediately see Bobby Flay and he's
selling me something from Lipton iced
tea so what's so [ __ ] up is and I
think it was actually I was actually on
the Huffington Post and I [ __ ] hate
those guys you know and they're all
liberal as hell can you [ __ ] believe
it's above it's like if you're making
money off of it you're making money off
of it so there's something you would
think on just something like this is so
reprehensible we shouldn't even put a
[ __ ] ad in front of it other than
that I understand you got to make you
money I have advertising on my [ __ ]
podcast but there was just something
[ __ ] up like this is the most horrible
blah blah blah whatever the [ __ ] they
have it's a headline and then you click
it on and it's [ __ ] Bobby Flay
selling me [ __ ] iced tea but you know
let's say the games played I guess
anyway so let's get the [ __ ] out of that
all right yeah boo Nazis boo Donald
Trump being a [ __ ] [ __ ] the guy such
a [ __ ] but I'm so sick of him and that
[ __ ] guy from North Korea acting like
they're tough guys
acting like they're tough you know what
I mean you know I think you know they
should put they should fight the [ __ ]
undercard on a McGregor Mayweather all
right why don't you guys settle your
[ __ ] beef I'd love to see the two of
them put on [ __ ] the whole [ __ ]
get up the box ensure it's the mouth
guard the gloves the boots and go out
there and you just really see what a
couple of pansies you know that fatty
Donald Trump with his [ __ ] wig
flopping around it probably one of the
fun it'd be funnier than all the
stand-up specials that came out this
year combined it would have been
tremendous like that's that's the way I
think that that's the way they should
solve world problems although you know
what's his face is like a black belt in
judo Vladimir Putin that [ __ ] that
dude looks like a bad guy like you know
no spy movies right right I'm in over my
head why do I try to talk politics
because that's what everybody's [ __ ]
talking
asking me about our guests but how about
those Red Sox taking 203 from the New
York Yankees I had a hundred bucks on
each game you know I got fifty with
virzi and fifty with my agent right
they're both Yankee fans so you know we
[ __ ] blew that first one down middle
reliever I don't know what happened a.m.
by the way you see that guy in the Mets
maybe swung his leg around made that
weird pitching motion and he [ __ ]
slammed his balls between his thighs and
then after that his [ __ ] pitching hand
went numb figure that one out
figure that one out why the [ __ ] are
guys wired like that why if you get you
could how the design fall of men that
you could throw an object and somehow
basically kick yourself in the balls and
then your throwing hand goes numb it's
unreal you know what it is the men are
like the Death Star right we got that
one little shaft all you do is you just
[ __ ] throw something down and then
the whole [ __ ] thing blows up and
that would be our nuts you know
I know what the women one is women you
just tell them they look older and then
that's it the whole [ __ ] planet
explodes ah [ __ ]
anyways I've been it's all out of number
ones going to talk about and I'm going
to having like the worst technology
[ __ ] weekend here I'm about to buy my
my second cell phone charger of the
weekend I brought one I left it at the
theater and then the next day I woke up
and I bought one time I bought one and
drove from [ __ ] where the hell was a
Red Bank New Jersey up to Tarrytown New
York and then I don't know what happened
I don't know where the why you went i
but I [ __ ] lost that one so now I got
to go buy [ __ ] otherwise just no my
phone my [ __ ] computer just keeps
cutting out
I guess now that I hit the escape button
I'm fine I don't know I'm uh I'm just
not meant to live in this [ __ ] era of
all of this [ __ ] I need to go back to
one that was just like rotary phones
which was impossible to lose because you
wouldn't take it with you it was just in
your house the only way you lost it is
if it was a [ __ ] sinkhole on your
house and you lost all your house so
there was a fire in your house you know
or somebody came to murder you with the
black gloves and they would [ __ ] cut
the phone wire then you lost your phone
and you lost your life but you say you
didn't care right was this simpler I'm
trying to say was it was a simpler time
I got to tell you dude I'm [ __ ] sold
on the Jersey Shore by the way all these
years all these years of Paul virzi
great call virzi [ __ ] crushed his
special last night it's been [ __ ] on
New Jersey a [ __ ] fight finally the
saying goes like - yeah I know what your
deal is with this [ __ ] state I don't
know why you think you know there's more
animals that live here than New York
there are I'll give them that it's a
little dirtier animal in New Jersey but
no there weren't that the underdogs so I
was going around Tarrytown I was just
taking pictures of people all the
[ __ ] animals that are up here what it
is about this part of this neck of the
woods like [ __ ] Westchester is it so
[ __ ] beautiful up here it cleans up
the animal you don't see it but if you
really if you [ __ ] block out the
trees and the beautiful houses and
buildings behind these people and you
really look at them you know it's a
bunch of em I went into Tarrytown and
there was a bunch of people like at all
the all the new rage now you seem that
those those their motorcycles but
they're really small
he's called many bikes but they look
like it's like somebody took a ninja and
they just made it smaller like this
whole group of them who's riding through
like a motorcycle gang I don't they were
mocking motorcycle gangs I have no idea
I don't feel more likely to beat the
[ __ ] out of you because they're insecure
about the size of their motorcycles I
don't I don't get out what [ __ ] works
but there was like 40 in the wing all
riding through town and I was laughing
my ass off don't here I am Here I am in
[ __ ] you know if I'm not
Westchester Robinson was just look at
these [ __ ] animals and I already
learned up here there's already there's
always this snooty thing in all of
[ __ ] real estate you know you above
the boulevard you below the boulevard
are you in the flatlands are you in the
Hills are you on this side of the tracks
or that side of the tracks this side of
the river other side of the bridge up
here I already found out that there was
business snooty if you live on the other
side of the Tappan Zee Bridge or the
Tappan Zee Bridge is there's my [ __ ]
Google map lady was saying when I was
driving up there make it right to go on
to exit one see four Tappan Zee Bridge
yeah you're less than you live on the
other side of the river stuff is cheaper
over there it's more expensive to live
here therefore you are less than me you
are less than God likes you less God
loves everyone but he loves you less
because you live on the other side of
the [ __ ] River actually cornered this
woman last night who was in real estate
right she's up at the bar I'm going up
there to go get a couple rounds of
drinks or whatever people you know
because I'm a hell of a guy
and she's like I yeah crazy special yeah
it's great you know I did a typical
comedy what do you do she goes I'm in
real estate
I said wonderful I got some questions
for you and I [ __ ] grilled there but
went law and order honor and I [ __ ]
was breaking it down to find out what's
the deal with all of these luxury
apartment buildings they're going up
like [ __ ] like luxury apartment
buildings that's how many luxury
apartment buildings they're building in
New York and Los Angeles
the only reference is what they are and
I'm like what is it wants to deal with
these [ __ ] luxury apartments who is
building them why are they building them
what kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] pays rent
in a luxury apartment when they could
actually just go buy something and live
in it that was less than the luxury
apartment but at least they would own
that who makes that dumb decision first
of all who's
for these and she said it's a lot of
foreign money China Russian Middle East
money right then I go alright then who
the [ __ ] living in them and she said
she basically said I go I sit who's dumb
enough to throw money in the toilet like
that she said about 15% of the
population I go all right so you're
banking on I go how do you put your head
on the pillow every night she goes this
isn't my passion I go but you're selling
them how do you do that how do you
[ __ ] go all right come on lower 15
percent dummies please walk into my
office today
lunch story short I go when does it
burst when she goes well you know there
you know people seem to keep building
them in Quito when does it burst well
you know but when does it burst she goes
two years dead serious she goes two
years two years it's going to be [ __ ]
over here's what you do I go you sit on
your [ __ ] money all right if you need
to buy something now because the [ __ ]
there's me I'm like that [ __ ] bald
guy who screams about taxes I mean are
the stocks I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about but from that little
[ __ ] conversation I had about 3:30 in
the morning as we were closing down this
[ __ ] bar celebrating Paul Berg Z
question is special I'm telling you
right now just sit on your [ __ ] money
like I don't what the [ __ ] did I say
initially I guess I said yeah if you if
you're getting killed in taxes and you
got to buy something now just don't rent
a [ __ ] a [ __ ] luxury apartment
there's got to be the dumbest [ __ ]
thing you could ever do look at the
luxury of this all look at all this and
luxury that I'm paying for that I don't
[ __ ] home just hang in there in two
years you'd be able to buy the [ __ ]
building of course you won't because
it'll still cost millions adults but you
know what I'm saying don't be a [ __ ]
SAP all right all those building to do
doing is killing everybody's [ __ ]
view you know they're all going to be
[ __ ] empty within two years now I'm
calling it right they're all going to be
people it'll be jumping out of those
[ __ ] things in two years we're taking
call this
I don't know and I'll [ __ ] know all I
know is I haven't been home in too many
days I miss my daughter my wife and I
can't wait to get back and that's it I
got a nice 10 days off but dude I had
the best [ __ ] time down in Jersey
Shore the [ __ ] food was amazing I
went down to this place juniors I don't
even know where I was at all right like
I was pretty cool I had a different
opener every night virzi opened the
first night [ __ ] killed it I went to
bed like a goddamn angel like a [ __ ]
angel
all right I'm already white as a [ __ ]
angel you know at least a ghost went
right home went to sleep woke up the
next day worked out [ __ ] crust it
right next day I had [ __ ] bread
guards came up who absolutely [ __ ]
murdered who you have to go see I hadn't
seen him in years it's weird I always
see him down the comedy store but he
that just went up or I'm going up or
what I'm going up and he's going up in
the other room I just hadn't seen him in
a few years that dude grown by leaps and
bounds absolute [ __ ] monster
destroyed he had me paste in a little
bit flow is going up and off a French
killing that's killing [ __ ] what am i
opening with right and then later on
that night he took me down to wherever
the [ __ ] he was took went down this
place juniors someplace on the Jersey
Shore and we got a tomato pie which I
had never heard of which is basically
it's like a South Jersey Philly thing
where according to them they put the
cheese on first then the tomato sauce
but the one that I had looked more like
a swirl of look like tomato cheese
tomato cheese like a big [ __ ]
circular think like when you [ __ ]
computers refreshing that little
pinwheel thing that's what it looked
like [ __ ] I might have been might
have been one of the top five pizzas
slices of pizzas I've had in a while
okay and I'm going to tell you why
because I live in Los Angeles and all
the pizzas out there sucks even the
stuff that they say is good you know it
all [ __ ] sucks
every [ __ ] last place in LA
absolutely [ __ ] sucks I don't know
why you just anything that involves
dough sucks the bread sucks the pizza
sucks
suck all of that sucks however you know
other than that they got a tremendous
[ __ ] pasta sucks but you know amazing
steak houses burgers Thai food Mexican
food that's what you do out in LA but
you do not get pizza you don't get bread
you don't do any of that [ __ ] and I
thought I was coming from that eating
that [ __ ] to go into this it was [ __ ]
I'm their dad in the [ __ ] muscles the
bread with the [ __ ] sauce it was
unbelievable like an [ __ ] I'm eating
this [ __ ] it like [ __ ] 2:00 in the
morning and then I kept going to this
place Elsie's in Red Bank to get a
sandwich and gesture I would pay for
just the bread alone by the way I went
with the turkey with the cranberry sauce
over there
[ __ ] delicious and I made the mistake
of getting a large by the way which was
the size of my [ __ ] legs so the next
day I went back and I got the Italian
which was amazing but I still like the
turkey a little bit better so I was
eaten as my stomach growls here I was
been eating like a [ __ ] King out here
and I don't know I kind of fell in love
with the Jersey Shore always wanted to
see Asbury Park went down there check
that out went into the hallways every
place down there's like Bruce
Springsteen or Jon Bon Jovi played here
I know the place is not called the
[ __ ] Stone Pony
that's a [ __ ] bar I used to drink in
in the [ __ ] village that is no longer
there that was my [ __ ] spot I didn't
used to drink in there back when I had
my drinking under control then I was
hanging out with all the comics I hung
out with back then didn't drink and we
go and then we used to play [ __ ]
video games and shoot pool and just give
each other [ __ ] like we always think for
like four or five til four or five in
the [ __ ] morning whatever that
[ __ ] pony place is called I know it's
sacrilegious all you jerk I got a look I
got to look you know why I'll get the
name of it right now because I bought my
daughter a onesie from that place and at
which I think she'll only be able to
wear for one week because it looking at
the site it looks like it's the size
it's years now which of course my wife
had to say oh it is a stone pony
oh wait this
crow is the Baris to hang out it alright
so I was saying it right I sent the
picture the ones who to my wife and she
immediately goes like what size is that
cuz she's currently wearing you know
this month to this month it's just like
at Jesus can you just you know can I do
one [ __ ] thing right over here
something one thing can I do that
so last night I hung out till 4:00 in
the morning but I only had a couple of
[ __ ] drinks because I kind of
realized I'm not an elk I'm like an
undiagnosed strength of Alcoholics you
know where I'm the classic alcoholic
where I can't just have one like I'm
doing it I'm [ __ ] doing it that's it
alright but the next day I can just be
like alright well now you know now I'm
not drinking then I walk around like I
need it man I [ __ ] need it I don't
wake up like missing a tooth and all of
that [ __ ] [ __ ] like but you know I
had way too many that night when I went
down to juniors and had that great food
and everything I also noticed too I was
thrown aback like like [ __ ] water and
it's just not a good thing I'm just sick
of being [ __ ] hungover so you know
last night I only had a couple I'm time
I think I'm done I'm just done with it I
like waking up not [ __ ] hungover I
like it not going to the [ __ ] gym I
like doing that [ __ ] and yeah I'm not
saying I'm done for [ __ ] good but I'm
just kind of just yeah I'm done I had a
hell of a run all right started at
[ __ ] 17 drank until about I don't
know 22 and then I went like a 10-year
period where I didn't drink I barely
drank barely [ __ ] drank and then then
a guy named Joe DeRosa came into my life
it's not fair for me to put it on him
all right but does just say we were not
good for each other and that was
probably 2004 so I'm talking like a nice
third I've gone down like a 13-year sort
of although I took a year off one time
from 2010 to 2011 a year I didn't went a
year in two days without drinking I've
gone a couple stretches of 75 days 50
some days here or there whatever but uh
yeah I mean I'm always you know you get
a nice cold bottle of [ __ ] wine it's
a good meal maybe I'll have a glass but
I just don't feel like but then it's
like I'm blue I'm going to finish the
[ __ ] bottle I mean what are we doing
here right so I don't know I don't feel
like I'm mature enough at this point my
life to handle [ __ ] like that and I'm at
the point to whether I don't think I
even enjoy it anymore so for the 90th
time on this [ __ ] podcast I'm going
to try to stop drinking so I was a
social drinker I think I want to go to
AAA just because I like crowds you know
just go up there and stuff [ __ ] make
them laugh and [ __ ] anyways what am I
talking about here how many minutes in
over 27 minutes in here I gave a cait
this [ __ ] hotel room I'm staying at
this stupid-ass [ __ ] you know fancy
[ __ ] looking to share it in right
people as yes date the [ __ ] Sheraton
these [ __ ] I swear to God you order the
Internet at 12:01 it goes off and you
got to buy it again oh wait maybe it's
free all I had was an access code I know
I take that back they're not [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right let's let's let's read a
little bit of uh let's read a little bit
of and I'll by the way that nothing to
Yoda I don't look like above Trump
supporters is when they compartmentalize
that racist [ __ ] when they go like you
know I got stuff where he doesn't
condone you know he doesn't uh chastise
the Klansmen that not neo-nazi said like
him I don't like that I don't like that
part but I'll tell you I think the way
he's handling
they've been Hilary you know no I can't
[ __ ] stand either but at some point
you know what I mean it's like if you
had a friend right he's a good friend of
yours but he was also in the Klan dude
he's such a great host you have them
over you know he [ __ ] he's really
polite but he drops the n-word I mean at
some point you don't you have to have
some sort of a standard you can't tell
me that there's not a better Republican
out there all right please tell me
please tell me there's something
somebody better than this guy
all right oh here we go oh it's old but
Gerta are you hiring will are you
you think the Klan uses zip recruiter do
you know where you're poked where to
post your job to find the best
candidates talk about the best qualities
your employees have well my employees
meet and I'm going to tell you when I
look in the mirror when I brush my teeth
I'm like god damn it
there's a [ __ ] hungover guy that
really gets the job done
with zip recruiter you can post your job
to 100 plus job sites with just one
click then they're powerful technology
efficiently matches the right people to
your job better than anyone else
that's why zip product is different
unlike other job sites if recruiter
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them in fact over 80% of jobs
posted on now there's no more sentence
on the zipper crew to [ __ ] focus you
know they find the right person no
juggling emails or calls to your office
simply screen rate and manage candidates
all in one place with zip it is easy to
use dashboard find out today why zip
recruit has been used by businesses of
all sizes to find the most qualified job
candidates with immediate results and
right now my listeners can post jobs on
sip recruiter for free that's right for
free eh girls just go to zip recruiter
comm slash bar that zip recruited us -
but typically rock club / / hey one more
time
try for free go to zip comm / / alright
oh look everybody Dollar Shave Club
Dollar Shave Club is dismounted choice
you get a great shape and a great price
conveniently delivered right to your
front door
you no longer have to schlep to this
door like other than going to Yiddish
you know the one can help to schlep to
the still Susan Blumstein calling buy a
buy it cheap disposable Rize that give
you a cheap shave or spend a [ __ ]
fortune on razors with gimmicky shaving
technology that you don't need and when
use Dollar Shave club's executive razor
with the dr. cavities easy shape the
blade just gently glides giving you a
smooth shave dr. carver shea butter is
transparent for a more precise shade
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights
razor bumps make the smart choice by
joining the Dollar Shave Club revolution
for a limited time new members can get
their first mount month of any executive
Raider with the tube of dr. Kennedy's
executive sheet for only 5 dollars with
free shipping then that and that after
that sorry razors are just a few bucks a
month that stiffed a 15 dollar value for
only 5 bucks there's no hidden fees and
no commitments cancel anytime you like
you can all you can only get this offer
exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / alright
yeah you know what i watch the other day
then i really enjoyed was i watch this
whole thing on John Daly that guy has to
be one of the most honest human beings
one of the most honest human beings ever
you know it's kind of hard watching the
guy what he does to himself but like I
swear to God like remember in Scarface
when that guy goes I like you Tony
there was no lying in you you know
there's lying and everybody but John
Daly I think he could give they should
recast they should
[ __ ] green-screen him in there you
know can somebody photoshopped in and
somebody just says I like you John Daly
there's no lying in you they just be
like you know how much the high do you
drinking were you drinking a day because
I drink like a case of beer some days up
to maybe thirty five forty they go
thirty five forty like alia and then
they go and then one because I am I
probably switched to whiskey and then he
just started laughing like just be like
I know it's [ __ ] up talked about how
he played his best golf when he was a
little drunk II you know the balls you
know you just hit the ball better you
know you looser body relaxes and I
really wish I watched golf more when he
was playing because he didn't take all
that [ __ ] time when he went up to
address the ball he just went up and he
just [ __ ] hit the thing crushed it
like seriously watching that guy swing
is one of the most incredible things
I've ever seen in my life I actually saw
some [ __ ] idiot did that thing where
he put the tea in his mouth with the
ball and let Jon Daly do a John Daly
swing anyway
Daly didn't [ __ ] up thank God but I got
to tell you something if you ever took
that to the city he would have killed
him he literally would have killed that
guy he would have gone to jail you know
with that guy from the [ __ ] New
Jersey Nets right he shot that limo
driving and you would be in that row
they have a roller cells of athletes who
accidentally killed somebody he would
have been right there you know what did
you do I shot my limo driver would you
do a you know I try to hit a golf ball
out of this guy's mouth and I I missed
and I kid his head how far do you think
John Daly could hit a human head that
was still attached to a body so he has
to rip it off the body I could say get
hit at least 17 feet that's the level of
torque and power in that man's swing so
check out John Daly videos if you get a
chance at work I it sounds crazy it's so
[ __ ] like it's an overly used
expression but refreshing when you watch
the guy he's not trying to hide anything
just like I
still now in time there was a rain delay
and you know just went in there may be
other two golfers you know we just got
hammered just got absolutely hammered
and the next day we came out in the same
clothes hungover we actually will play
grape all right more advertising upside
there's an upside down boy you turn me
there's a better way upside down calm
you're turning me I wish it wasn't what
I was there was one less supplement
syllable illness so I could [ __ ] it
really make that song happen there's a
better way for you to buy business
travel you know one thing I've learned
about these [ __ ] people that
advertise evidently they all have a
better way of doing something
it's called upside calm ball you tear me
every time you buy a trip at upside
you'll save your company a ton of money
and they give you an Amazon gift card
worth hundreds of dollars
Amazon gift card worth hundred dollars
upsides able to do this because they
bundle your flights and stick you under
the plane with the luggage no and a
hotel together they bundle your flights
in the hotel together for one low price
bundling prices saves money if you're a
frequent business traveler your company
saves a ton of money and you can get
thousands a year in gift cards just for
buying your air and hotel together
upside plus you'll get all your miles
Jesus Christ is a [ __ ] coming next I
mean what more what more do you guys
need here if you're shopping for I just
got rid of all the females well is there
a free pair of pumps coming to ladies if
you're shopping for business travel
you'd be [ __ ] crazy not to check out
up side calm boy your termi Amazon
giftcard I'll work it out I'm working it
up okay believe me everybody does this
all the Great's this is how they write
their songs it just it takes just three
minutes to see how much you can save by
buying your flights and hotel together
for one low price and right now we'll
use my name Burke be you are our
you are guaranteed to get at least $100
Amazon giftcard your first trip that's
my name bar to get at least $100 Amazon
giftcard for free okay
think of how many widgets you can get
for that hundred dollars one of those
[ __ ] fidget wheels whatever the [ __ ]
they call it save big on travel and get
a big gift card every trip evidently I
love upside calm according to this copy
upside calm minimum purchase required
see site for complete details all right
the last one this is those last
worthless free simply safe sorry my
voice is if the [ __ ] three shows it's
a little [ __ ] messed up here summer
is prime time for burglary oh my god
Jesus I'm scared so now is the time to
protect your home for a limited time you
can take a whopping $100 of simply safe
special summer package this is simply
States the biggest ever summer sale it
has everything you need to protect your
home an arsenal of security sensors were
an Arsenal security sensors to secure
each door and window are you at econo
you're simply safe system comes with a
panic button Jesus Christ now I'm
thinking about the chick from [ __ ]
Silence of the Lambs Jodie Foster a
blaring extra siren and a wireless
connection to authorities and police
dispatch your family your home and
everything in it
stay safe around the clock with simply
safe there are no long term contracts
installation costs and no hidden fees
and 24/7 professional monitoring is just
$14.99 a month get $100 off the summer
security package at simply safe bird
comm if you guys knew what was going
through my head right now this sale ends
September 3rd
that's simply safe bird calm to get your
$100 off simply safe bird calm do you
remember in the panic room
when she had to go out of the panic room
and she went back in and she went to go
back in there was like some issue where
maybe she would have caught her [ __ ]
arm in the door and I was just thinking
what if she [ __ ] did and it closed
and then she had to make the decision do
I reopen the door expose my kid to the
bad guy or do I just sit here while my
arm slowly just [ __ ] dies and then
then I'll die in here you know
see this is why I don't write movie
scripts because that would [ __ ]
happen ever you're like oh my god it was
terrible and she [ __ ] died the kid
saw it and then he couldn't figure out
the code and then everybody died right
it was a double feature
after that we showed the local news
white people this is oh god we're going
to get into the raishin are we really
going to get into the ratio gay white
people Oh Billy ambassador I'm sure I'm
sure you address the current events at
the top of the plot this podcast I
skipped over most of it as you may have
heard I just sort of trash Trump for not
having the [ __ ] humanity to trash you
know some of the dumbest people on the
planet you know and actually blaming the
people that they attack also I still
[ __ ] get it um he goes I'm pretty
moderate and have the same Ron Paul
ideas above government as you seem to
have sorry about the generations trying
to keep it tight yeah dude I don't even
know what the [ __ ] I believe anymore
he said I watched my Facebook feed all
day denounce white people all right
first of all why would you go on a
Facebook feed are you trying to depress
yourself are you trying to make yourself
an upset why would you go on there what
did you do next did you go on Twitter
and look up hashtag white people so you
can infuriate yourself more and get in
even more like delusional view of what
the population is like you know I don't
know I mean if you watched all that [ __ ]
about the Klansmen you think that every
white person was in the Klan I mean it's
just I don't anyways plowing ahead here
he says I look white but I'm
first-generation American with my
parents coming from Italy okay yeah
you're you're Italian okay I get it all
right
my policy on making general statements
about entire races is I don't in
stereotypes sure white people love
things like jar jams but in criticism I
never say white people or black people
because if history has taught us
anything it's the dumbest thing you
period I think you meant to say the
dumbest thing you can do he goes I'm
tired of it all day white people disk
white people that I voted for Barack the
first time I hate Nazis and it's [ __ ]
pathetic that I have to say that out
loud
I think Trump is a [ __ ] I hated Hillary
I don't wish for the south to rise again
I'm not offended as a white person I'm
just tired of the laziness of it am i
way off here look I know what you're
saying but dude it's like is this the
worst thing you have to deal with you
got to expect people in a highly
emotional state
all right such as this you know when
you're in a highly emotional state
you're going to say stuff in a way that
you wouldn't if you were a little more
relaxed and then secondly if you're
going to [ __ ] go on a Facebook feed
and get upset I don't have any sympathy
for you like it's you know it's a
Facebook feed there's no the
qualifications to comment on Facebook is
you have to be smart enough to sign up
for Facebook that's it so that's what
it's not a think-tank it's not a TED
talk which even those things I'm
starting to think of just a [ __ ]
bunch of snake oil salesmen everybody
acting like something [ __ ] amazing is
happening you know because somebody's up
there with a laser pointer talking about
the future yeah I mean all right I
understand what you say like I'm not
going to lie to you there are times
where I'll see like these people being
applauded for [ __ ] that they're saying
and when I'm listening to what they're
saying it's like if you took out white
people there and then you inserted black
people like that and that person was
white they would be in trouble however
however you do have to take it with the
grain of [ __ ] salt
because of the great [ __ ] life that
you have all right and I don't know I
think you should maybe try I would try
to listen more to what the overall point
is rather than wasting time being
offended you know I'm a white guy and my
[ __ ] life is great you know and
pretty much go whatever the [ __ ] I want
to go I go down to the mall and buy a
t-shirt and Oh buddy [ __ ] with me right
I'm not saying it's easy but I mean
compared to what other people compare
what else beep to [ __ ] have I guess
this is the best you know this is the
inside lane you know I can [ __ ] look
the other way but there's definitely
days I'll say that there's definitely
days that you know non-white people say
some [ __ ] or like you know women will
say stuff about men being like that's so
[ __ ] overtly [ __ ] sexist and not
only not being called out on it
you're being applauded for it like
you're brave and what you're saying is
just as [ __ ] ignorant as what the
[ __ ] you're doing however at the end of
a tie you kind of got to be like well
because of what's happening it's so
[ __ ] pissed like I give it a little
bit like I just give it a little bit
depending on my mood I do that but uh
alright you know what the honest thing
is is if I'm sitting there and the
person who isn't white says it I'll get
into a debate with them alright but I've
been with all white people and they're
complaining about it I'll tell them to
shut the [ __ ] up I think I'm just a
contrarian it all depends I don't
[ __ ] know but all I do all I know is
after watching all that [ __ ] horrible
[ __ ] and I just think you know there's a
certain level of empathy that you should
try to tap into try to put yourself in
other people's positions a little bit
more and I don't know I guess to try to
compensate for the astounding level of
[ __ ] ignorance that's out there I
guess you got to try to make yourself an
even better person or somehow I don't
know I don't know what to tell you
because I'll be honest with you is when
all people go hey I'm not in a [ __ ]
well not in the Klan I'm not a Nazi guy
I'm not I don't belong a hate group bla
bla bla non [ __ ] everybody has their
[ __ ] issues and when your comedian
it's like you're running for
it's like you run this campaign that
never [ __ ] stops and you're meeting
people like I was just in Red Bank New
Jersey now I'm in Tarrytown now I'm
going to go to [ __ ] in LA you know the
end of the month I'm going to be in
Boston in New Hampshire then over me in
Mississippi and Alabama
am I really promoting my upcoming dates
talking about racism look at me next
thing I should have Bobby Flay reading
this but the point is I'm going to meet
all these [ __ ] people and I don't
know I gotta be honest with you
everywhere I go no matter where I'm at
when I'm in a room and it's just all
white guys of a certain age my
generation and older you can literally
take a [ __ ] I swear to God like one
of those sands of time timers and just
go okay when is the n-word coming I'm
trying to remember I'm trying to
remember the last time that you know it
doesn't happen every time but I go in
there I literally start having anxiety
going Oh God you know I look around and
what I'm doing is I'm judging too and
I'm like when's it coming someone's
going to [ __ ] save or someone's going
to say something a little borderline and
it's depressing like I was hanging
recently on a road gig and it was all
white dudes in there and Mayweather
accused McGregor is saying something
racist and McGregor's going oh you know
I didn't focus say anything racist bah
bah bah bah bah and all this type of
[ __ ] right
and then this random white guy is
watching he goes see anyone - what's a
big deal
he's like this guy's an n-word and that
guy's whitey I mean it's a fight who
gives a [ __ ] what you say and I'm just
thinking in my head like dude they're
not saying he said that like like but
that is like that's how his [ __ ]
brain processed that information and
it's it's I don't know it's it's so fun
it's depressing
because you know what it is everybody
thinks they're smart and everybody
thinks they have it figured out
you don't mean think about what is the
last time your Emmy sometimes your
conscious gets to you but does your
brain really ever say like I mean it
takes a lot to [ __ ] admit that you're
wrong regardless of color sex or
anything like you know what I shouldn't
have done that I was wrong I you know I
now realize how [ __ ] ignorant that
takes and to truly mean it not to just
get on the good side of your wife again
social baingan right to truly [ __ ]
sincerely mean it and then try to make
it change it takes a [ __ ] lot and for
anybody so I don't know so I bought some
things like you know if somebody does
says that what do I do
do I [ __ ] confront them do I get into
the [ __ ] debate I tried every [ __ ]
technique but get up and walk out every
[ __ ] affected nothing works
nothing [ __ ] works and it's
depressing so I try to avoid that social
situation maybe that's what I'll do in
the future maybe that's what I'll do in
the future
anyways that was like that time I would
if I remember the [ __ ] I was when I was
in I was in Durham North Carolina that
[ __ ] guy goes you know bill I like
you you know you're a good person you
know you know Bill because I like
meeting good people then I was like I've
got here comes I like meeting good
people he sees testing the waters he's
taking his towing you know Christian
could Christian people white people and
then BOOM the [ __ ] Edward comes so
that guy headed off the path he's a guy
I like meeting good people I was just
like oh yeah do you you know I like
meeting bad people who the [ __ ] doesn't
like making good people and then he then
he shut up
then shut up and then he got really mad
at me you know when I was talking about
you know
I don't like the Middle East or
something like that I was just going
like do they another like us you know to
me they got a couple of crazy [ __ ]
leaders and then everybody else it's a
bunch of you and me walking around there
trying to get sandwich you know you and
I were trying to get the [ __ ] in the NBA
package and they're trying whatever
[ __ ] sport but what's sporting into
over there soccer right everybody's into
the [ __ ] soccer anyways so yeah I
don't know I understand you know but I
don't know I I don't I don't I don't
have any [ __ ] answers I don't [ __ ]
know all right
younger girlfriend not ready for
marriage okay hi Phil I'm a big fan of
yours it would like your advice I'm a 35
year old guy from the Bronx
dating a 20 year old Japanese girl in
Japan I love her a lot and want to marry
her but she tells me she's not ready for
marriage and children yet and can't
really say if or when she'll be ready
yeah it's because she's 20 he was I love
her but getting married and having
children is very important to me if I
were younger I would say okay no problem
and just keep dating and see if anything
changes but at 35 I'm starting to feel
pressure to get married sooner rather
than later
that's a sizable pressure but I worry
that I'm getting too old to be a father
well I just had one of 48 so Alec
Baldwin's [ __ ] knocking him out in
his fifties he said I'm okay right now
but in five or ten years I feel I might
not have enough energy to run around
chasing little ones and if she's still
not ready in a few years that would put
me in a very difficult position and
you're thinking smart sir I'm happier
than I've ever been with her and
happiness can be so fleeting that I
don't want to ruin it with what I have
with her but at the same time I can't
wait forever what would I do
I would I would listen to I would listen
to logic all right
I I really think you know most of the
time you know if who's dragging their
feet to the altar it's usually the guy
okay not the woman why would they for
the most part
generally speaking they're marrying
somebody that makes more money than them
so there's no fear financially if you
[ __ ] you know they're not going to
lose half the house they're going to get
the whole house and they're going to get
a [ __ ] check from you that's
basically what the [ __ ] happens you know
it's like the showcase showdown at the
end of the price is right and you're the
guy that I go hey thanks for playing and
you just walk off and then everybody
crowds around the person that won that's
usually the woman in marriage okay and I
don't hear any [ __ ] from women because
all you guys do is [ __ ] that you don't
make as much money as men so what I'm
saying computers going to say that's not
the [ __ ] case then what are you
bitching about [ __ ] equal pay for all
right either you make it less are you
not alright so beauty sit there being
saying I love you I want to spend my
life with you and [ __ ] have children
with you and start a family and live
happily ever after for her to say I'm
not ready for that yet and I can't
really say if or when I will be ready
yeah dude she's 20 years old she has no
idea the [ __ ] she is you're you're
you're [ __ ] 15 years down the road
you know who you are you know what you
want and I don't think she's going to
figure that out with you you know you're
taking their best years away from her
where she should be out [ __ ] scene
figuring out what the [ __ ] she wants and
you in your best years of because now
you're ready so you need to go out and
meet a [ __ ] mature woman it was it
not mature I'm not saying this woman's
immature she's not even she's [ __ ]
twenty all right this is what happens
this is what happens when you when
there's that level of an age difference
at this age okay look if you were 45 and
she was 35 she'd be [ __ ] you know
pressuring you I don't know dude I would
just hate for her to at 23 to be like
you know what I don't
this isn't like what I want and now
you're 38 you pushing for you don't want
that I think I would
pull the ripcord now you know that's
what I would do I don't [ __ ] it up I
mean it's hard for me to tell you to
[ __ ] break up with somebody over a
paragraph of information on a podcast as
I sit in a bed in the hotel room isn't
it
so take all of that with a grain of salt
all right you know what I would do sir I
would ask you good friends ask you good
friends with the [ __ ] they think because
they know you and I'll actually have to
have a nice long [ __ ] distance phone
call with you I guess you're in Japan
right now I would do that you know or
maybe get some friends into Japan I
don't [ __ ] know that's a big decision
but just from that little information
yeah I get out of it you know
and I'm also saying don't do that
because I don't [ __ ] million right
jacy's Christ oh did you waffle any more
than that one Ari I dump my girlfriend
and now I regret it it's just the
follow-up song to I kissed a girl and I
liked it
hi Bill I started watching your podcast
watching my podcast I don't how you're
doing I mean listening to my podcast
well this person's not from this country
or doesn't speak English anyways I'm
going to read this right is the same way
this person wrote it I started watching
your podcast
since few months because the best
Romanian stand-up comedians always said
that they listened to yours in their
podcast get the [ __ ] out of here
Romanian comics listen to this podcast
shout out to Romania huh is that where
all the gypsies come the Richard Pryor's
and George Collins of [ __ ]
pickpockets I got to tell you man
they're [ __ ] amazing
they're pains in the asses but Jesus
Christ can those [ __ ] people pick
your pocket you almost like till they
leave you can't find your passport you
almost [ __ ] applauded him I don't
know where you are but I was good I had
no idea
god bless you I don't know if they come
from Romania the gypsies Transylvania
they're gypsies they move around now
about the story me and this girls we had
a complicated tooth you got a threesome
you come broke up with two girls
I had a complicated story and I tried
six months to be what their until I
finally succeeded so after one year and
a half a very nice relationship he's
given it to her
of course with ups and downs before I
leaved to Germany to study I decided
alone that will be better for her if we
split up so I dumped her and said to her
that we should remain friends my
decision was because I got scared of her
love she would leave all of her dreams
and stuff only to come with me and be
with me auntie to hear that at 19 years
old
is scared it's scary as [ __ ] now after
nine months when the moving out euphoria
has vanished I now know that I made a
big mistake and I realized how [ __ ] I
was to her I think you mean Kunti in the
past month so she moved on but we still
kind of talked but I cannot sleep
anymore I developed a little problem
with drinking alone and trying not to
feel something a little advice would be
nice thank you and all good for you and
your family
first of all [ __ ] you did great with
your English I know exactly what the
[ __ ] you were talking about I could
never do that well I don't know what you
guys please speak over there as it gives
it called Romanian cap and Zi don't you
nineteen you're going to meet somebody
else I mean on your way to find the
person you're going to you're going to
be with your [ __ ] up like anything any
success story you make mistakes and you
learn from them along the way all right
if you really love her I mean this is
what you could do call her up one time
and just say listen I just want you to
know that breaking up with you was the
biggest mistake I've ever made
I've had a problem sleeping I've been
I've developing trying to forget and
just tell her why you did it
and just totally communicate with her
and see what see what she says all right
and you know if she doesn't take you
back you can live with that okay the
bottom line do you [ __ ] 19 years old
okay don't start drinking don't do don't
make the mistakes I make all right
you're in the prime of your [ __ ] life
turning around wake up every morning
have some positive thing that you say to
yourself all right as simple as today's
going to be a great day
all right [ __ ] up that relationship
but so and so but I forgive myself and
I'm going to go out that door and I'm
going to be a [ __ ] real life you know
you're going to track somebody else to
you go out there have a good time and
when you meet a woman right that you
like it just just [ __ ] be straight up
on it how you doing man I'm trying to be
positive trying to be positive when
through some [ __ ] I'm trying to get over
it and I'm trying to be positive what's
going on with you there cutie pie start
doing that don't [ __ ] start drinking
it being a sad sack you know drinking
again Oh baby I'm drinking again alright
that's it but this is a good this gonna
be good experience for you you can learn
how to [ __ ] open up as a guy
communicate your feelings and learn how
to [ __ ] get closure with the woman
that you broke up with or who knows it
opens back up who knows right and then
also you learn how to not make self to
see you learn how to pick yourself up
off the [ __ ] mat because I'm going to
tell you right now you're 19 years old
if you think this is the first time
you're going to get knocked on your ass
in life you're you're sadly mistaken
alright you got to learn how to get back
up again so this is a great opportunity
no matter what alright so there you go
grasshopper take those positive words
and go help yourself a great [ __ ] day
all right how do you make friends after
turning 25 now Jesus quite believe me
just I don't know buy a round of drinks
he says my man BB no fun dude that dead
that old Billy no fun is complete
[ __ ] I've been having too much fun I
have been alright and I've been having a
problem turning off the fun faucet if
you know what I mean I'm struggling here
alright there's always a reason there's
always a reason how we just shut a
special boom we're eating [ __ ] tomato
pies bang oh I'm on a [ __ ] flight and
the guy asked me if I want to drink
bazooey all right
big fan you may have had this question
before but I've moved into a new town
and I've learned that I have no guy
friends
I mean I'm plowing
like crazy through these apps but I miss
just going to the bars with the fellas
okay so I'm coming I'm an old guy so
you're on these dating apps and you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] man
good lord how [ __ ] easy is it to get
laid Jesus Christ because I keep trying
to arrange to go out with guys from work
but they all commute in from another
town and have girlfriends they need to
tend to I find myself going back to my
hometown a lot of the weekends to see my
buds of laying pipe with miscellaneous
chicks where I live so my very sad
question is how does a guy make friends
Cheers
oh you poor baby you're just out there
bagging all these chicks you know what I
would do I'd [ __ ] to hang out with
them I just started hanging out with
them the [ __ ] do you care you can always
find a [ __ ] crew of dopes to go watch
a [ __ ] game with you know what I was
I don't I don't know he said Cheers so
much assuming you're [ __ ] somewhere
over there and Great Britain what do
they say in Australia - I don't [ __ ]
know anyways do you play sports go play
some pickup hockey go play some [ __ ]
softball go places you pick up soccer
football whatever the [ __ ] you call it I
would do that I would get involved in
some sort of an activity sports related
if you're into like I don't know you
don't sound like you're into comic-con
[ __ ] considering all the women you seem
to be [ __ ] so yeah I would I would I
don't know I'd rather do something like
that is there an app for that I have no
idea all right what time is it here
attached me to wrap this up my
girlfriend doesn't appreciate me ah my
girlfriend doesn't appreciate me poop
hey Billy back fast I like that one
I'm a 21 year old guy currently
unemployed well what if I yeah you're a
guy without a job that's like being a
woman without kids we went to [ __ ]
vagina
yes women that's what we look at you
like I'm sorry we are we're [ __ ]
animals blame God that's how were wired
I'm a 21 year old guy currently
unemployed and I live with my girlfriend
and we've been together for a year and
I'm and I'm a year in seven months now
recently it seems like she doesn't
appreciate me anymore
yesterday when she was at work I made
her coffee did the laundry for her
partisan pizza and then picked her up
and all I heard that night was how I
didn't rinse the dishes enough before
putting them in the dishwasher she
doesn't act like this
she doesn't act its way to anyone else
and I feel like I can't do anything
right around her would love to hear your
feedback and go [ __ ] yourself yeah
here's the deal here's the deal all
right and you'll never get a woman to
admit this all right but one of the
great things about them having a
boyfriend is that he's going to pay for
[ __ ] he's going to take him out he's got
a buyer buyer stuff right he's going to
[ __ ] you know your job as a man is to
provide okay a woman you know after you
give you push her off the dock with your
Johnson there she can make a [ __ ]
baby all right and then immediately just
be the greatest [ __ ] mom and it's
[ __ ] magical to watch what can we do
we pick up heavy [ __ ] that they can't
pick up and we go out and we earn a
living
here's the thing as a man the second
you're sitting there and you don't have
a [ __ ] job and she does and now she
gets to feel what it's like to be a man
which is you [ __ ] come home right
you've busted your ass all day you know
if you're [ __ ] young you don't have
your dream job yet unless you're Justin
Bieber or somebody like that and you
made it
for professional sports generally
speaking your 20s is the struggle of the
dream hoping it comes true at some point
you [ __ ] 30s so she's coming home and
she's seeing you sitting there like a
little [ __ ] homemaker and you know
every guy sometimes you know when you
come home and you look at your wife
stays at home your girlfriend stays at
home and you just look at so you don't
have any kids it's like what the [ __ ]
did you do all day like every day
Saturday but you what the [ __ ] you know
but at the end of day like I have a good
thing she's you know she she's [ __ ]
beautiful she's banging me you know all
that [ __ ] that guys to think of
important but for women you got to
provide them you got to get a [ __ ]
job you want you want your girlfriend to
[ __ ] respect you again you got to get
a [ __ ] job
you got to start bringing home money
that's it that's it see what I do is I
actually I bring home money and I do the
[ __ ] dishes you know so then whenever
my wife gives me [ __ ] I could be like
flat what is the problem okay I'm like
[ __ ] Babe Ruth here I'm hitting home
runs and I'm pitching a no-hitter what
the [ __ ] else do you want what is the
problem see that you know why I can say
that because I have a [ __ ] job you
don't have a job sir so no matter what
the [ __ ] you do her problem with you is
nothing even rinsed the [ __ ] off it's
not that you did this wrong or you were
driving too [ __ ] fast it's the fact
that when you guys go out to get a
meatball sub she has to pay for it you
know yeah you want to see all that
feminism go right out the [ __ ] window
you stay home you be mr. mom that's what
happened here sir
what happened here sir is you stop being
a man to her the second you don't have a
job when you're with the woman you
immediately become like this [ __ ] 20
25 30 35 40 year old [ __ ] teenager
you they look at you like you're a child
that's it so you need to get a [ __ ]
job
I might late am I wrong I'm speaking for
you okay if you think I'm [ __ ] wrong
just right into the podcast and I'll
read your opinions and I'll make fun of
myself all right okay I got to go
out of this [ __ ] hotel that's the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in
on you on on Thursday and uh you know
I'm at you know after all that [ __ ]
depressing [ __ ] I saw in shoud so I'm
gonna try to be on time be [ __ ] nice
to everybody today all right I'm gonna
try to go on a nice little run up being
nice to everybody go out of my [ __ ]
way to not be a [ __ ] okay to be a little
more empathetic as I just trashed women
and spoke about them in a nice big
generalized way I'm basically a [ __ ]
hypocrite and for like me I can't
understand why you guys listen to me go
[ __ ] yourselves I'll see you Thursday